[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think architecture school permanently
broke my brain ever since those
deadlines the late nights in studios and
those traumatizing all-nighters i've had
the same recurring nightmare for years
and apparently i'm not the only one if
you're anything like me you'll know what
i mean according to experts hurry
sickness is a common illness today the
term was coined by cardiologists mayor
freeman and ray roseman who noticed that
a lot of their heart disease patients
had a very common character trait they
were in a constant rush
hurry sickness is defined as a behavior
pattern characterized by continual
rushing and anxiousness an overwhelming
continual sense of urgency
a malaise in which a person feels
chronically short of time and so tends
to perform every task faster and they
get flustered when encountering any kind
of delay
my thesis project was not only focused
on architecture
but it was also a investigation into
this phenomena of speed and distraction
and how it's affected our culture of
learning
and our places of learning instead of
trying to condense everything into one
10-minute video i've opted for the
unpopular solution break up the concepts
into a series of videos if you want the
whole picture of the thesis project you
will have to watch the whole series and
i'll leave the playlist right here
[Music]
thanks to technology were able to do
everything much faster instead of
walking we can drive instead of calling
we can text and why would you even
bother going through an entire book when
you can just control f
[Music]
i think with time being so intertwined
with a monetary value society has come
to treat productivity and
efficiency
as
one of
a person's most important traits when
you think about it it's kind of ironic
technology is designed to increase
efficiency
so
therefore it's designed to give us more
time
and therefore increase the quality of
our lives
but
instead of
giving us more time to think and relax
it's kind of bred a global push towards
productivity
[Music]
me
[Music]
however when we're productive enough
when we cut up and save up enough time
we're rewarded with free time
or what we call leisure leisure is
defined as time when one is not working
or occupied free time use of free time
for enjoyment opportunity afforded by
free time to do something although
leisure is a state of mind the modern
dictionary can't define it without the
incorporation of time
in fact time has become the benefactor
that affords us the opportunity to do
something we have become enslaved to
time
where even the most personal of concepts
such as leisure have become commodified
into multi-million dollar industries
this constant acceleration has led to
this problem of distraction
and ultimately has reduced the quality
of our lives studies have found that the
more you spend time in this distracted
state the more you reduce your brain's
capacity to focus
or reflect for long periods of time
permanently although the issue of speed
and distraction is more prominent than
ever
it's actually not such a new phenomenon
in our culture for centuries people have
been trying to find silence in the midst
of all the noise
during the medieval times priests would
embark on a journey through a labyrinth
for meditation a labyrinth is an
indirect and arduous path to a clear
center and is often the longest possible
route to the destination the paths are
non-linear inefficient and often
disorienting
but they have one route from entrance to
the center and without the possibility
for false options and these paths are
used to reach a contemplative state
without the fear of getting lost the
idea of a labyrinth is a contradiction
in the era of speed where we always try
to find the shortest and the most
efficient route possible the term
labyrinth and maze is often used
interchangeably however the two race
different ideas a maze has a complex
branching of paths with possibilities
for different routes and dead ends a
maze is designed to deceive its walkers
misleading them into multiple directions
and potentially instills a higher sense
of uncertainty and confusion than a
labyrinth so i have no idea where i am
right now we've been walking for about
20 minutes and
we're kind of back where we were before
you can see the
arch
[Music]
in both a labyrinth and a maze we're
comforted by the knowledge that we will
eventually reach the end which allows us
to become intentionally lost and this
kind of offers a way out from the chaos
that we
experience a lot of the times i have a
pretty hard time articulating this
feeling i'm gonna read you an excerpt
that i've modified and adopted from one
of my favorite books larry's party by
carol shields
i hadn't anticipated the sensation of
being unplugged from the world
without thinking i slowed my pace
willing myself to be lost to be alone
here in this labyrinth getting lost and
then found seemed like the whole point
i observed how my feet chose each wrong
turning turning against my navigational
instincts circling and repeating and
bringing on a feverish detachment
i think we've been here before
[Applause]
[Music]
venice is a network of canals and a
network of streets which span and
intersect each other therefore the
shortest distance between two points is
not a straight line but a zigzag that
ramifies its tortuous optional routes
this is from the book invisible cities
by italo calvino where he describes a
conversation between marco polo and
genghis khan where marco polo is
describing all of these fictional cities
but actually he's just talking about
venice
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
uh
[Music]
the experience of walking through venice
is composed of two fundamental
sensations of compression and of release
we experience compression in these
narrow alleys and we move towards our
only clue
which is the light at the end of the
tunnel which is also a promise towards
an opening
maybe it'll lead to another valley it
might lead to an even narrower alley or
it might lead to a small square despite
the discomfort that we might feel we're
no longer really in control and we have
to surrender to the environment
the release offers us a sense of relief
we finally enter this open space with
everything in front of our eyes and we
can finally see our surroundings and we
can see people again you ready for the
big expansion
[Music]
it's brighter and it's safer and the
contrast between the narrow alley
makes it seem like a larger space and
then we enter the alley again and this
dichotomy continues on and on
frank lloyd wright used this method a
lot in his designs he would encourage
you to move through in the compression
spaces while creating this moment of
pause and the
significant release in these larger
spaces we kind of go from the unknown to
the known when i visited venice for the
first time i'd made this really long
list of places that i want to visit but
i was confronted with people and books
telling me over and over and over again
that i need to experience venice
just the way it was designed to
wander without a particular destination
and that's basically what i did in fact
there's a term for this and it was
coined by ghee de bod in 1967 and the
situationist movement and the
situationists were these group of
avanguard revolutionaries they were
known for their critique of advanced
capitalism and their fight for
individual expression and they were also
known for their long walks they coined
this term called the derive which
directly translates into drifting they
define the reef as an unplanned
unexpected passage through an urban
landscape where participants stop their
daily routines and allow themselves to
be drawn by the attractions of the
terrain and the encounters that they
find there the situationist
internationals used venice as their
ideal site for experimentation they
would drift through these narrow streets
and follow their senses
and through its
unpredictable network of streets alleys
and dead ends canals and bridges the
derive became a journey through ambient
space and ambient intensities for
navigation through the labyrinthine city
and it becomes a really powerful
strategy in slowing down your pace
[Music]
thank you for watching my very first
attempt at turning my very complex
thesis into a short video this is just
the beginning of the process so if you
are interested and if you want to
continue on the journey make sure you
subscribe and the next video is going to
come out next month
so
i will leave that video right here
otherwise
if you want to keep updated with what
i'm doing i have a monthly newsletter
i'll leave the link to join in the
description box and this type of video
is not sponsored
the production cost is coming out of my
own pocket
and this type of video i know performs
really poorly on youtube analytics
but
right now i'm really interested in
exploring this bridge between
architecture and filmmaking if you
enjoyed this video i would greatly
appreciate it if you try to generate
some buzz around it like share it
comment on it donate to it by clicking
on the super things let me know your
thoughts your genuine thoughts down in
the comments so let me know if you want
to see the rest of the series
and if not
that's okay and with that i'll see you
in the next video bye
[Music]
you